stationary points you let sorry this is
station okay
Letty why the X be equal to zero but
also remember that you don't want this
to just come out of the middle of
nowhere
okay so let's actually do an example
okay um a question with me find all the
stage for the recorders for y equals x
squared okay so what do you do the first
thing you do is differentiate okay now
here's what I want you to avoid okay you
know in your head you're like okay the
direction I'm heading in is this okay I
want ey next to be equal to zero so an
instinctive next thing to write would be
2x is equal to zero okay because that's
what you're going to solve okay
however it just kind of comes out of the
middle of nowhere in terms of your
working it's like well when is is true
is it always true why are you working
this out okay so therefore this is the
thing I couldn't chords before okay in
between these lines I would say
stationary points exist when dy 1 DX
sorry y equals 0 okay and rather than
the same therefore here this is actually
not a conclusion this is something I'll
try to work out it's the problem so I
say it's there therefore I say I as in
you know station points exist when I do
do 0 and what that looks like that is
this okay so then you solve it okay now
what I've done so far is I've found the
x value for the stationary point okay
but in anywhere else on the court in
geometry if I said find a point I don't
just want an x value I also want a Y
value right so you found the x value how
do you find the Y value bring it back to
your original equation okay so I would
say when
zero y equals zero squared which is also
zero okay so again I'm trying to avoid
you know the next line being y equals
zero like where'd that come from
it's kind of random especially when
you've got more workingman so I'm gonna
say why am I looking at y equals zero
it's when x equals zero that's the value
a okay so now that I've done am i
working I'm going to conclude I would
say therefore there's a stationary point
at zero sir okay I you're really sure to
write stationary point you're really
should address there's no way I want to
say look at the beginning right we want
to introduce acronyms as we become more
comfortable this stuff this is really
new for most of us right and this is the
first exam when you're getting here so
stat points a little better to be honest
at it I don't think I ever remember
while getting take it off for something
as pure on them you know does that the
other but we're just trying to firm down
the topic and like I don't want you to
start doing ESPYs for so long from the
beginning and then you know 6 most
ladylike what is it this week I don't
know dance or something I want you to
get one anyway so that's how I find a
stationary point that's not too hard